this is journey's end for one of the few
remaining routes out of russia
two trains a day run from saint
petersburg to the finnish capital
helsinki
it's a service that has seen a five-fold
spike in bookings since the start of the
war in ukraine i'm not sure we are
coming back in like one or two months
because
we are afraid of staying in moscow right
now anything could happen and we're
afraid that the borders might close
we're afraid that
the economy might not recover many of
our friends left russia they went to
georgia they went to
dubai
airspace closures have created
bottlenecks for russians with the means
to leave hundreds have queued at the
border with latvia
a seat on the helsinki train can mean an
onward flight to anywhere in the world
but tickets are hard to come by
these trains were running at 20 of
capacity before the start of the war now
they're fully booked with around 500
russians arriving in finland every day
some are returning to russia too
but the numbers coming into finland are
set to rise
so now we're adjusting i want to add one
more train per day
starting from the next week so we're
just negotiating about that we want to
keep the train traffic open that people
can travel uh from russia and of course
also back to russian if they have some
reason to travel on the platform few of
those we spoke to were actively
emigrating some work in finland others
are seeing family while they can or
getting back to homes abroad that's the
only link
left you know i mean for people to go to
relatives and
it's terrible situations it's like
somebody is dead in your house i'm 50
percent
ukrainian 50 percent russian so for us
it's a huge tragedy
while that tragedy continues it's
ukrainians who need a safe haven here
and elsewhere in europe
as the number of refugees approaches two
million
paul reese al jazeera helsinki